important than party and politics it's
about the people he represents
how bad is it congressman
look you know i i've seen the 2014 surge
i've seen the 2019 surge another 21.
uh usually you have high peaks from
march april may and june
but now we're in july going into august
and we're not seeing this stop
uh you know you we have to put attention
first of all to our border communities
prioritize the border communities
and then also we got to think about our
men and women that are doing this work
they don't want just a pat in the back
they need support they need
equipment they need personnel and we
need to understand that there's a
serious situation
down there at the border we know that
the code the the vaccines
there are are not prevalent in central
and south america and the top 10
countries where these people are coming
from
so they're coming over here excellent
chance they're going to be spreading the
virus
does the administration realize this
there's no testing going on
well you know i i don't know the
administration knows it but i can tell
you that the men and women
on the ground uh you know border patrol
or even uh
customs uh they understand because look
in the valley there were 70 agents that
have tested positive in the laredo area
another 15
it's not only the agents but it's also
their families when they go home
so we have to prioritize our men and
women of homeland and we have to
prioritize definitely
the border communities i had for example
i've had
county judge richo cortes a democrat in
hidalgo where all this is happening
he called me yesterday and said we have
to put a pause
in about an hour so la jolla we're
having a phone call
you saw what happened they released
people in a hotel
but nobody watches them there were some
of them that were sick they were
positive
walking around and nobody told them that
they got released in la jolla texas
that's part of my community
and i want to talk to those officials in
about an hour or so
congressman if if the administration
listened to you they could fix the
problem you got to turn
people around right away send a message
to central and south america you've seen
the top 10 countries where they're
coming from
this has been stopped before how come
they don't listen to you you're a
democrat
with a border community as your
constituency
well you know again you know they they
don't have to listen to me they need to
listen to the border communities and the
border communities are saying
hold up put a pause my hometown of
laredo
they filed a lawsuit against the federal
government saying we don't want any more
buses of
migrants coming in the county judge of
webb county put a declaration saying
we are going to stop uh border patrol
buses from
bringing in any more migrants into there
because cases have shut up
our hospitals uh are getting full
we don't have the personnel uh to work
at the hospitals because a lot of them
have been
uh sick so this is what we're facing
they they don't have to listen to me
but they need to listen to the border
communities
to the border communities and they
certainly need to listen to the men and
women they don't
just want a pat in the back they need
some real help
now and we're in a pandemic and they
told us the the migrants were going to
stop
and because it's so hot and they're
still coming congressman cory
you're doing you care about uh the
american people more than party
and it's so rare today i hope people
start listening to you
thanks so much for joining us